how would you differentiate between
equity and equality Bernie Sanders who
has pushed more of this socialist
nonsense on America than virtually
anyone and by the way the revolution
will eat him and it will be beautiful
but you may remember this Bernie Sanders
the Socialist in America with three
houses uh here is Bill Maher asking him
the difference between equality and
equity and he doesn't even fing know Dei
are we confusing equality of opportunity
with trying to guarantee equity and
outcomes okay that's interesting because
I think this word Equity has come into
the language in the last few years and
before that we didn't hear it a lot and
I think a lot of people hear equity and
they hear equality that it's the same
word and it's not the same word and the
same concept so how would you
differentiate between equity and
equality well equality we talk about uh
I don't know what the answer that is
come me to think of it you know uh
equality is equality of opport
opportunity all right we live in a
society we want all people right to have
whatever color your skin is equity I
think is more guarantee of outcome is it
not no I think so I think that's okay so
which do you come which side do you come
down on uh equality equality yeah okay
everything that Bernie Sanders has put
into the American system and run on and
the Progressive Movement that he largely
birthed in America has been based on
equity and he did not even know I mean
Bill had to drag it out of him without
completely embarrassing him although
that should have ended the grift right
there so on one hand if you call them
out on their hypocrisy they tell you
it's a stupid question that's what John
krey did then Bill Maher asks Bernie
Sanders the simplest question what is
the basis of your beliefs and he doesn't
even know the difference between
equality and equity and the problem with
all of that is when you have a bunch of
people who are either Liars or idiots in
charge then the policies that they
create destroy your lives right because
if you think that people can't make
choices for themselves then generally a
bunch of people who don't care about
them are going to make all of the
choices